- [Voiceover] It's election season again.
We've already had multiple debates,
so the big day must be just
around the corner right?
Wrong.
Election Day 2016 is November 8, 2016.
That's 366 days away.
Let's put that number in perspective.
The 2015 NFL season from kick-off
to Super Bowl is 150 days.
That means almost 2 1/2
seasons can fill the space
before the next election.
Any bones broken during this season take
on average six to twelve weeks to heal,
which means you could consecutively break
and heal four different
bones before next November.
Okay, so let's talk gestation periods.
A human pregnancy lasts about 280 days.
A baby conceived today would
be nearly three months old
on Election Day.
Even llamas who take their sweet time,
with a gestation period of up to 360 days,
if they get started now,
they could still pump one out
before the vote.
Fruit flies have a lifespan about 30 days.
That's around 12 generations
between now and Election Day.
In human time, that'd be almost 300 years.
Alright, forget the
Earth. Let's go to space.
The Apollo 11 mission went to the moon
and back in eight days.
366 days would accommodate 45 trips.
Forget the moon.
NASA's rover Curiosity made
it to Mars in 252 days.
That's more than 100 days
less than it will take
for us to know the next
leader of the free world.
Last month, Canada finished
its longest federal election
campaign since 1872.
So how long was it?
78 days.
So chill out, America.
We've got time.